joe biden has now been in office for 14
months inflation is at 40-year highs gas
prices have hit all-time highs we're
witnessing the first major war in europe
in 70 years some people believe we're
all on the brink of world war three
and to top it all off there's not enough
food
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries in our country as
well
the food shortages are going to be real
he says
as though that's just a normal thing in
america
food shortages something that we have
not had in this country in what
90 plus years i'm think what the great
depression was that the last time even
then food shortages in the richest most
powerful country in the history of the
world
and a president who just sort of shrugs
it off like that's normal
we managed to survive biden's winter of
sickness and death just to find
ourselves in the springtime of famine
and hunger can you even imagine what
biden's got planned for summer
over the past two years things that we
never thought could happen in this
country have become realities seemingly
overnight
full-scale lockdowns church
closures federally mandated muzzles an
economy that just stops now food
shortages as we stare down the barrel of
a great power war in europe
i am no fan of barack obama but even a
stopped clock is right twice a day
obama was dead on the money about one
thing
we should never underestimate joe's
ability to f things up i'm michael
knowles is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from thursday is from jordan l
who says i wish i could afford a
subscription to the daily wire so i
could watch fouchy unmasked but i'm
saving up for a full tank of gasoline i
know joe that's another thing joe biden
screwed up people used to have a little
bit more disposable income so that they
could do things like subscribe to the
daily wire and watch fouchy unmask my
three-part docu-series on the real
history of dr fauci you have not seen or
heard this before luckily a lot of
people still
maybe they're just going to fill their
tank halfway this month so that they can
make the wise choice to invest in that
subscription thank you to everyone who
has watched fauci unmasked who cares who
cares about filling up your tank okay
there's other things to worry about even
on your car and when you want to fix up
your car you got to check out
rockauto.com
right now go to rockauto.com write
knowles in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you to
the one and only place you should ever
be getting your auto parts time is
valuable gas is expensive do you want to
drive all the way over to the brick and
mortar auto parts store wait in line
answer a thousand questions about your
car then the guy goes in the back they
don't have the part there's too many
parts to stock now then you pay 30 50
maybe a hundred percent more for that
part
than you would at rockauto.com that
seems crazy to me are you a masochist
don't do that sort of thing you know
rockauto.com the website is so easy to
navigate even i can do it they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years they've got everything that you
want
no gimmicks just reliably low prices you
head on over there you pick out whatever
part you need same prices for pros and
do it today
rockauto.com and most important of all
because we love rock auto and we really
appreciate them coming on sponsoring the
show having the guts to stand up
with a conservative show uh write
knowles and they're how did your best
box so they know that we sent you
we will get
to the famine we will get to world war
iii we will get to all of the
pressing national and international
political issues
but first i've got to talk about the
issue
that that everyone is most concerned
about this morning that would be the
slap heard round the world
no i did not watch the oscars last night
no you did not watch the oscars last
night no i don't think anyone watched
the oscars last night
but we all saw this trend and then we
all tuned in for this clip when chris
rock made a joke about will smith's
wife's hair and will smith got up and
smacked him across the face jada i love
you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it all
right
[Applause]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i james keep my wife's
name out your
i'm going to okay
so i could oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay all right well that's fine the
greatest night in the history of tv he
said chris rock recovers pretty well
here over what a joke about
jada smith's hair so jada smith has hair
loss she's losing her hair
apparently the medical condition is
alopecia some people have alopecia from
a very very young age and they don't
have any hair at all jada smith has had
hair her whole life but she has now has
hair loss as she's getting older and
chris rock made a joke about this and he
said okay here's g.i jane two because in
g.i jane demi moore has very short hair
and will smith sort of laughed at this a
little bit and then he decided no and he
gets up and he smacks chris rock across
the face and
then starts screaming there are so many
angles to this story i think though i
have the least conventional tank take so
some people think it was staged because
the oscars have been losing viewership
for a decade now and they wanted to get
viewership back up it doesn't look
staged to me yes it's a room full of
actors it could have been staged it
seemed real
so i i don't think that's the case
i don't know that chris rock would have
agreed to it maybe he would have i don't
know i so i'm going with the assumption
that it was
real
the joke itself was pretty mild by
hollywood standards he was making a joke
that now she's got
very shortly cropped hair because she's
losing her hair jada smith could have
turned this into a kind of
strong yes i am woman hear me roar kind
of moment yeah i am g.i jane i'm a tough
lady
but that that didn't happen
she was a vet she was offended okay
that's why it's fine to be offended on
behalf of your wife of course if your
wife is going to be in show business in
public life at an event where people
make these sorts of jokes then it seems
like that's kind of what you're signing
up for but okay will smith decides that
he's going to get up and defend his
wife's honor i actually have no problem
really with the slap is it an
overreaction probably
is it a little
uh
unconventional it wasn't really called
for by the joke itself i'm not so sure
we can debate that i
i actually think we would live in a much
better culture if every time someone
insulted our wives even during an awards
show someone got up and just smacked him
across the face because it didn't look
like a punch to me it looked like a
corrective slap
sorry demand satisfaction slap right
across the face i think that's a good
thing i think we lived in a better
culture now we live in this culture
where we're told that anyone's allowed
to say anything they want they can talk
about your wife they can talk about your
mother they can talk about your god they
can say whatever they want and you're
never allowed to go up and have a
corrective smack across the face and
it's because we've made an ideology out
of a complete distortion of what free
speech really is
the founding fathers were the great
defenders of free speech in history but
they would not have tolerated someone
insulting their wife or daughter or
mother they would have gotten up and
smacked them across the face and
probably dueled them to the death okay
so that i i actually think we would live
in a culture that was more dignified
more focused on honor if we could do
this the smack
what
will smith got wrong here is that he
then sat down in the chair and started
screaming profanities like a lunatic
keep my wife's name that's very
uncivilized
that is very
and the poor man i don't think it had
anything to do with chris rock's
joke i think will smith has been
publicly humiliated for years now by his
wife who is boasting on television about
how will smith is the biggest cuckold in
america and will smith has to just sit
there and take it
i don't i don't think it was the joke
about his wife that set will smith off i
think that was the straw that broke the
cuckold's back and he went out and he
took out all of his rage on the on the
men that his wife is bragging about
sleeping with he took it all out on poor
old chris rock chris rock total showbiz
professional
one takes the smack like a man barely
even flinches then goes on makes a
couple jokes this is the greatest night
in the history of tv and moves on uh
good for the oscars it finally got them
a little a little play
but don't don't take the wrong lesson
don't take the wrong lesson from this
incident the right lesson is
if someone insults our wives and our
mothers and our daughters or whatever
and you give them a little corrective
smack i like that that's a good call we
should we should develop that culture
but don't lose your cool don't lose your
temper temper and start screaming like a
maniac and using all sort of profanity
and make them bleep you out that
not very manly at all that's the most
important pressing issue today if you
look at twitter if you look at the news
if you look at what everyone's talking
about
and in a way it is we need it we want a
dignified culture of honor the rest of
the oscars night
was not so engaging the rest of it was
kind of a joke because hollywood is not
a serious place in america it doesn't
seem any longer to be much of a serious
country they opened the oscar show with
wanda sykes and amy schumer and some
other chick i don't know who she is and
they got out there
and they were going to make a stand a
stand against the oppressive system and
they were just going to say gay a lot
we're gonna have a great night uh
tonight and for you people in florida
we're gonna have a gay night
[Applause]
gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay
wow that's so brave and insightful wow
did you just said gay gay gay gay gay
gay gay a lot oh
you some of the wealthiest most
influential people in the world
wow
you said that word
that sort of sexual preference that
everyone's allowed to say and encouraged
to say and frankly forced to say a lot
of the time
and you're defending a political
ideology that every power center in
america enforces wow
so brave
you you tell those parents in florida
yeah wanda sykes and amy schumer you
rich powerful influential famous people
you tell those parents who don't want
their kids to get trans by radical
teachers you tell those parents who
don't think five-year-olds need to be
taught about weird sex stuff in
their kindergarten math class yeah gay
gay gay gay wow so smart
so so smart during the during the awards
show about an industry that's supposed
to entertain us that's supposed to be
about the customer entertaining the
customer the viewer
edifying us teaching us
showing us some other aspect of life
yeah you tell them
gay gay gay gay gay gay we're not a
serious country
we're a country that
has food shortages we're a country that
doesn't respect our constitutional
rights anymore we're a country
that is potentially in the brink of
world war three and the best that our
elites can muster is gay gay gay gay gay
gay gay gay that's what they're shouting
by the way one thing one thing that i
would recommend shouting is shout out
have you ever wanted to send your uncle
a birthday greeting from one of his
favorite conservative celebrities or
have your favorite freedom-loving
comedian roast that one liberal cousin
that no one likes in the family well
there's only one place to make that a
reality it's a new app called shout out
the most popular personalities on the
right are ready to make someone's day
with a personalized video download shout
out right now on the app store and
google play to get 20 off your first
customized shout out video from the
likes of stephen crowder the hodge twins
jp sears jason whitlock or alex jones
and many more of your conservative
favorites you just download that app you
download the shout out app and next
thing you know you could be telling your
your
liberal cousin skyler schuyler they're
turning they're turning all my freaking
cousins gay if you
if you downloaded the app it sounds like
an incredible amount of fun so head on
over to the shout out app today and get
it in the app store you can get it on
google play and make the day of your
conservative friends and loved ones or
maybe your liberal ones too we're not a
serious country anymore
speaking of
hair
and speaking because for for will smith
and chris rock speaking of hair speaking
of
unserious political issues
while we
have a failing economy well we have food
shortages while we have potential war
overseas our geniuses in congress are
focused on the real issues namely
banning hair discrimination
you know on the list of national
problems
uh record high inflation record high you
know where does hair discrimination fall
on the list i would say somewhere around
17
gazillion
number 17 gazillion no according to our
congress it's right up there at the top
the house passed a week or so ago
the crown act
h.r 2116
passed in a party-line vote by the
democrats that would ban hair-related
discrimination crown stands for creating
a respectful and open world for natural
hair and prohibits quote discrimination
based on an individual's texture or
style of hair and the the reason for
this this was a totally foreign concept
to me but they say that quote routinely
people of african descent are deprived
of educational and employment
opportunities for wearing their hair in
natural or protective styles such as
locks cornrows twists braids bantu knots
or afros
and now we need to stand up
and ban hair discrimination
is this a is this a very serious problem
in america
no it's not
one sometimes you need to discriminate
against certain styles of hair
not you're not discriminating on race or
to attack someone but you
in certain industries you need to
protect hair from getting into food for
instance or from getting into mechanical
equipment and you actually can't allow
people to wear their hair in certain
ways the military is clear but you need
to have your hair cut nice and short in
most
parts of the armed services
because that's what the job requires
so you just need sometimes you actually
do need to discriminate on hair not
because of someone's race not because of
someone's religion or background or just
because of the hair itself certain jobs
require that and that's fine and and if
you need to wear your hair up in a net
or you have to cut your hair short for
certain jobs you know what you can do
deal with it just deal with it and suck
it up and stop making everything about
you and stop taking every requirement of
put on you by
your job or your society as some kind of
personal affront it's not just deal with
it and suck it up because people have
real problems like food shortages
we're living in a world where we're on
the precipice of world war three and
where people are going to starve
according to the president of the united
states and you're complaining that you
don't get to wear whatever fun hairstyle
you want to wear
stop it stop it not everything is about
you
not everything is about your
desires
be they well the one we mostly hear
about
is sexual desires which is why the left
has to just say gay gay gay gayle that
the legislators in florida marching down
the hallways saying gay gay gay the
people at the oscars
but it's not gay to me now seems so
antiquated so traditional because now
it's not the g or the l or even the b
it's the t and the l and the q and the
seven and the ampersand and everything
else but it's cut it out it's not about
you
ask not what your country can do for you
that's not what your employer can do for
your hairstyle that's not what what how
you can fulfill your own
desires ask what is required of you stop
living in a society that's based
primarily on rights most of which are
fictional at this point and start asking
what what duty do i have what obligation
how can i make my society better that's
what a serious country would do but we
are no longer a serious country
in a serious country people deal with
issues of justice of law of order this
story just comes out in new orleans a
group of teens with a criminal record
just stole the car of a 73 year old
grandmother and drove it off while she
was still attached this is a little bit
gory obviously we're gonna there's video
of this sort of thing
which thankfully has been blurred but as
they steal the car the woman falls out
of the car her arm is ripped off and
then she dies 73 year old grandmother
because these criminal teens were not
dealt with by the criminal justice
system and so they were free to wander
around and and then they killed this
this woman
the superintendent of police in new
orleans sean ferguson describes
the incident
ferguson did say he wants the teens
charged as adults brazenness broad
daylight
with no regards to this woman
hanging from the vehicle so i mean i
think at some point in time we have to
step up and say we're going to hold
individuals accountable yes sean
ferguson the new orleans police
department they got it right we've got
to hold people accountable these kids
should not have been out allowed back on
the street they had this criminal record
they
you're seeing this not just in new
orleans not just with teens but with
everyone there's a movement to let
criminals off the hook and it's being
pushed explicitly by democrats who
explicitly want to defund the police who
want to abolish police departments who
want to abolish federal prisons there's
congressional democrats very prominent
ones who are trying to abolish prisons
entirely at the federal level
now this police officer says this is bad
we got to hold people accountable but
the poor woman who was killed here
her boss was asked what
what he thought about the incident what
he thought should happen to the kids and
obviously he agrees with the police
officer that they should be punished he
just doesn't have any faith in the
system i have virtually no confidence in
the system right now
does anybody you know i would love to
see them be prosecuted as adults
send a message not only to
somebody who would be thinking about
doing that but this you know what is the
purpose in it what purpose was this it's
a senseless murder
he has no faith in the system nor do we
nor do we because crime is not punished
because criminals are let off the hook
criminals have been recast by democrats
as the real victims and the victims are
somehow the perpetrators of the crime
because of society those poor teens
they've been failed by society it's not
their fault
but of course it is their fault they
made a decision even even teenagers can
make decisions sometimes even teenagers
have to be held accountable or at least
rehabilitated but no we live in a in a
country where up is down and left is
right and right is wrong and true is
false
we live in this country where the elites
the ruling elites have upended
everything where now the best woman
swimmer
is a man right where the criminals are
the victims
where everything is upside down and the
elites don't need to deal with the
consequences of that
this is the key this is how it's allowed
to go on
because if the if the elites if the
people who were setting the society
people making the laws the people
forming the culture in hollywood the
people
deciding what information gets out there
through big technology through the media
if those people had to deal with crime
on the street like that 73 year old
grandma were
mark my words those teens would be
rotting away in prison for life
at best
that would be that would be the luckiest
case scenario for the teens okay
if
the elites were dealing with crime
throughout our cities
there wouldn't be crime for very long
they wouldn't be talking about
abolishing the police or defunding the
police they would be privately funding
uh
police departments and jails to
incarcerate these people forever but
they don't if beyond crime
if the elites were dealing with the
negative consequences of say immigration
you you bet your bottom dollar that
southern border would be sealed tomorrow
if the elites were dealing with the
consequences even of the crazy sexual
ideologies even of all the other of the
of the food shortages of the high gas
prices if they were dealing with that
then we would have national policies to
mitigate those problems not exacerbate
them which is what we're getting
but they don't have to deal with the
consequences of it
and so now there's a backlash and we
talk about republican versus democrat
and left versus right and those
distinctions do still matter the
partisan and ideological ones but there
is
a a class movement that's come up now
the
people versus the ruling elites and the
ruling elites sometimes they're a
democrat usually they're democrat but
sometimes they're republican and yet no
matter who wins and whoever who's in
control the border gets worse crime gets
worse all these issues get worse and
worse and worse
this is what is meant by populism the
populist uprising this is what is meant
by the deplorables the irredeemables
versus the deep state right the idea of
the deep state the administrative state
the permanent government is that no
matter who wins the election the
policies remain the same
the deplorables the irredeemables the
bitter clingers they're not all
republicans
some are independent some are democrats
that what distinguishes them is that
they're not on board with the elites
agenda and the elites agenda has really
royally screwed up our country this is
not just true in america you're seeing
this reverberate throughout the west
immigration is probably the clearest
issue on this because it's the one where
the vast majority of americans want to
drastically reduce immigration illegal
yes but legal too
that includes a lot of democrats and a
lot of independents and a lot of
centrists want to drastically we're
taking in something like three million
people a year now
okay
two million illegally and then another
million legally that's just too many
people you can't maintain a coherent
country that way so the majority of
americans want to reduce that
the vast majority of politicians in both
parties
even if they would say we want to stop
illegal immigration they would almost
never say we want to reduce legal
immigration that's a bridge too far that
would be that's bigoted somehow i don't
know that's nativist it's xenophobic
and you're seeing that's why this
immigration issue it's such a it's such
a basic one if you don't have a border
you're not have a country this is
reverberating all around the world major
french poll
showing that 66 of french of the french
support the re-migration
of bad immigrants not not migration into
france migration out of france to kick
out the bad ones
now
when you want to talk about forget about
the bad ones for a second you want to
talk about the good ones you got to
check out tessa mays right now go to
tessamays.com use promo code michael
because you know me i'm of italian
extraction i like to eat well
and i want to eat healthy i want to live
a long time but i'm never going to
sacrifice taste that is not going to
happen well with tessa mays you don't
need to make that choice
tessa mays found a way with their
award-winning ranch dressings and
vinaigrettes to blend extreme taste and
healthy stuff too tessa maze is an
american-made company started by three
brothers with a dream to share their
mom's recipes with the world tessamese
puts flavor and quality above all else
and because of that they quickly became
the number one organic dressing brand in
the country all their products are
manufactured here in the usa they have a
wide variety of kosher whole30 and keto
products
whether you're in the mood for a creamy
avocado ranch or a light refreshing
lemon garlic dressing and marinade there
is a testament product for every
occasion kids parents and grandparents
can all agree on one thing tessa mae's
dressings are good on everything dipping
wings pizza pouring it over a fresh
salad go check it out tessa mayes makes
every meal better the embodiment of the
american dream these fellas they're
bringing manufacturing back to america
their products are incredible go to
tessamays.com promo code mike will get
15
off all their amazing products
t-e-s-s-e-m-a-e-s
dot com promo code michael
there is major pushback worldwide
against the ruling elites this is not
neatly ideological this is not neatly
partisan this is not neatly republican
versus democrat or left versus right
it's just the elites the people running
the country who seem to be able to push
their policies no matter who wins the
elections that's where the pushback is
and you see it most clearly on
crime and especially immigration and
you're seeing around the world including
in france
a poll found 66 of the french support
the mass
re-migration meaning kicking people out
of the country of illegal immigrants
foreigners on terror watch lists and
foreign criminals
out of france the poll was released by
ifop on behalf of sud radio
and it it showed that two-thirds of the
country supports this kind of thing and
a presidential candidate
on the conservative side who is causing
who has created a lot of energy and a
lot of support eric zamur who's running
on a defend france stop letting the
crazy globalist libs destroy our country
he is he is actually taking this on as a
policy he's proposing a ministry of
re-migration
that would send large numbers of
migrants back to their home countries
he's saying he would deport as many as a
million immigrants within the span of
five years
would he actually be able to do this i
don't know it would be an uphill battle
but is this a good idea yes this is a
great idea
a ministry of remigration you will never
hear me say that we need to emulate the
french
i i don't think i've ever said it before
in my life but you're gonna
now you will hear it i am on this one
idea a ministry of remigration
i'm not saying
i'm not saying that we should just kick
out anyone we don't like in the country
i'm not saying we need the mass
deportation of people on the basis of
their i don't know race religion
any of the sex or i'm not certainly not
saying that
i'm
saying what the french people are saying
here that on very narrowly tailored
lines we should be able to kick people
out
namely
illegal immigrants
foreigners on terror watch lists
foreign criminals
kick them out
of course
they never should have gotten here in
the first place
and the longer we allow them to stay
and commit crimes
the more we're going to get because it
shows us that we're not going to enforce
our laws this stuff is already against
the law
but michael it cannot be done well
maybe it can maybe it can't maybe
there's just a failure of political
imagination did you ever think
that we would get to a place in america
where the best female college swimmer
was a dude and we all were forced by our
employers by our schools by big tech to
pretend that that dude is a chick
did you ever no that's a monty python
sketch that would have been unthinkable
even ten years ago frankly even five
years ago probably and now it's
happening
why because the left whatever their
failures are they don't have a failure
of imagination
let's just do whatever did you think we
would get to a point in this country
where if you say maybe we shouldn't
slightly enforce our immigration laws on
the southern border you couldn't win a
democrat primary this is the party of
bill clinton saying illegal immigration
is a terrible horrible thing we've got
to stop at chuck schumer who's still the
senate majority leader same thing it's a
tour we've got to stop illegal
immigration then
10 20 years later you have to support
illegal immigration to be a democrat
they went from a place of abortion is
horrible it's a terrible thing but i
guess we should allow it to be legal for
whatever reason in some cases to
abortion
it should be on demand for that apology
we should be able to kill babies up
until the moment of birth and we're all
going to cheer and applaud that
you ever think we'd get to that point
the left did because they did not have a
failure of political imagination we
should not either
that then i totally support
emulating this would be such a popular
policy if a republican running for
president said we're gonna have a
department of remigration for illegals
for
foreign criminals for terrorists foreign
terrorists who are in america we're just
gonna we're gonna re-migrate them you
don't say deport that sounds too harsh
and we're going to re-migration is good
so we're going to re-migrate them
immigration's so good we're going to do
it twice
that would be so popular
all of the tv stations would scream and
shout and call everyone hitler and
and oh every bad thing in the world is
hitler according to those people so
they'd say it's racist right that's the
that's the synonym for bad they'd call
every the worst things you could
possibly be called that's what you'd
hear from nbc cbs abc new york times
washington post and you know
what the voters would say they would
love it the vast majority of voters
of both parties
i'm not saying the vast majority of
democrats but you get a lot of democrats
you'd get a lot of independence and
you'd obviously get the vast majority of
republicans it would be very very
popular
because it's common sense because it's
common sense why would we allow people
who are legally not allowed to be in
this country and who are committing
crimes in this why would we allow them
to stay you would have to be
an elite to think that was a good idea
you would have to be
you would have to have multiple degrees
from harvard and princeton you would
have to have a very high iq to be so
stupid to think that that's a good idea
that's that's the sort of thing only
only the elites could do
speaking of the rest of the world by the
way
um america may soon find itself even
more enmeshed with the rest of the world
because joe biden just promised the
troops
that they were they were about to go go
see the inside of ukraine and you're
going to see when you're there and
sometimes you've been there you're going
to see you're going to see women
young people standing standing in the
middle of the front of a damn tank
just saying i'm not leaving
i'm holding my ground
they're incredible
you're gonna see that when you go to
ukraine oops i mean biden didn't even
catch himself there
biden just said two american troops
you're going to ukraine that you know
that war in ukraine that's happening
right now where i've said we're not
going to get involved in that war you're
going
and you're going to see it when you're
there why are they going to see it oh
because you're going to send them there
the vast majority of americans do not
want america to be more involved in the
war the russian invasion of ukraine and
the war that's going on now and yet the
elites are pushing for greater american
involvement
almost all the elites almost all the
media apparatus almost all of big tech
almost all of the liberal establishment
is pushing for that
joe biden is pushing for that no one's
beating the war drums harder than joe
biden during a speech in warsaw
biden did not merely call for an end to
the conflict he did not merely call for
punishing putin he did not merely call
for peace
he called for regime change in russia
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power
god bless you all and may god defend our
freedom and may god protect our troops
thank you for your patience
thank you
he says this man cannot remain in power
which means he's calling for a regime
change
joe biden the head of the most powerful
country on earth is calling for regime
change in russia
russia a nuclear power how did regime
change go in iraq not great how did
regime change go in afghanistan not
great 20 years later we just brought the
old regime back
how did regime change go in libya not
great how did regime change go in egypt
not great
all of these places
not the most developed countries in the
world the the risks not so huge
now we're talking about russia russia is
not libya
russia is a former superpower with
nuclear weapons pointed at us
russia
the stakes are much much higher and
biden says ah didn't work the first five
times let's try it now with putin russia
by the way where there's no opposition
almost everything biden has done is
unify
russia behind putin putin was not
particularly popular in russia and yet
the crushing sanctions the attack on the
central bank has galvanized support for
for putin and there's no opposition
leader the closest one is alexei navalny
who has been imprisoned by vladimir
putin but even alexei navalny is deeply
unpopular in russia
he's a good-looking guy
he's pro-western he's not exactly
the
most democratic liberal leader in the
world but he's
it seems better than putin and yet if
you look at the levada center for
instance which is an anti-putin
anti-kremlin think tank
they are showing that the approval for
the opposition leader is 25 the
disapproval 75 so who's going to take
over russia
this is the liberals don't understand
this the progressives they're so utopian
they think things are always going to be
better we're going to go in and
everything's going to be roses what are
we going to do we're going to decapitate
the government and then it'll all just
be great
what's going to happen next
conservatives understand that sometimes
the devil you know
is better than the devil that you don't
the white house even the white house
not joe biden because he doesn't really
speak for the white house the rest of
the white house apparatus they realize
wow this is really dangerous stuff so
they just came out
they said the president's point was that
putin could not be allowed to exercise
power over his neighbors or the region
he was not discussing putin's power in
russia or regime change
but he obviously was they're telling us
now don't believe you're lying ears
don't believe you're lying eyes biden
said putin should not be allowed to
remain in power
in power
means in power
it doesn't mean putin should not be
allowed to invade ukraine that's not
what he said he said punjabi allowed to
remain in power he was talking about
regime change and then even the white
house came out and said no no he wasn't
and then biden was asked about this
later on by a reporter and he said oh no
i wasn't talking about that so even
biden can't make up his mind so now even
this show of american strength becomes a
show of american weakness then joe biden
in this disastrous
few days regarding the war in ukraine
said that if russia uses chemical
weapons not only are we going to start
fighting harder not only are we going to
push for regime change
we're going to use chemical weapons
ourselves
and to clarify on chemical weapons could
if chemical weapons were used in ukraine
would that trigger a military spot
response from nato
it would be it would trigger a response
in kind whether or not you're asking
whether nato would cross
we'd make that decision at the time
it would trigger a response in kind and
so what does the white house say
well the
national security adviser was asked
about this said uh president biden at
the conference yesterday said that if
russia uses chemical weapons in ukraine
the us and nato will respond in kind
which would seem to imply using chemical
weapons back is that what he meant by in
kind or what was he trying to say here
jake sullivan says no no you heard him
in another answer say we'll respond
accordingly meaning you know we will
select the former nature of our response
based on the nature of the action russia
takes and we will do so
i won't go beyond that other than to say
the us has no intention of using
chemical weapons period under any
circumstances so he sullivan just tries
to rewrite what biden said he says no no
forget about in kind
he will just respond accordingly but joe
biden said in kind in kind means the
same way so now joe biden is saying if
russia uses chemical weapons we
who and by the way we have said that
we've destroyed almost all of our
chemical weapons and we'll never use
chemical weapons and it's a violation of
international law but says yeah we're
going to do that we're going to use
chemical weapons in ukraine what would
that do
pushing us further
and further toward world war iii and why
because joe biden says that the war in
ukraine is is a battle between freedom
and autocracy he says quote we're
engaged anew in a great battle for
freedom a battle between democracy and
autocracy between liberty and repression
this battle will not be won in days or
months either we need to steal ourselves
for the long fight ahead he is saying
all but saying we are going to send
troops into ukraine we are in world war
iii we are going to
launch a or
escalate toward a global
military conflict
over ukraine
but this is not a battle
for for freedom exactly this is not a
battle between democracy and autocracy
between liberty and repression
this is a battle between two oligarchies
the oligarchy in ukraine and the
oligarchy in russia
that's not a justification of russia's
invasion i don't think it was a
justified invasion that's not to say
that the two sides are the same that's
not to say that there's a moral
equivalence
in the conflict
ukraine is the victim here russia is the
aggressor
it's a it's a nuanced complicated matter
but sure ukraine is the victim russia is
the aggressor but not every single
geopolitical conflict
is
a familiar ideological battle
this battle is not between democracy and
autocracy it's between two oligarchies
fighting over land a land
conflict that has been going on for over
a thousand years
is that
really
what we're going to launch world war 3
over
not every battle
is world war ii
the only historical comparisons that
liberals ever make are to world war ii
or maybe the fall of rome
but usually just world war ii because
it's the only conflict that they think
they know anything about there are other
battles throughout history there are
other fights throughout history
some nuance is required some
responsibility is required some
some sophisticated thinking is required
here and we don't have any of that we
have a really really degraded country
that is causing food shortages that is
now dealing with
mass inflation because we just keep
printing money because we think that's
the answer to our problems that's
dealing with all that all we can ever
muster is gay gay gay gay gay
gay it's all all we've got
okay
even if you
are
even if you think that it would be a
great idea to go and actually escalate
this conflict to de-escalate it with
russia say we need a big show of
strength the ukrainians actually are the
victims here and the russians actually
are the aggressors we agree on that and
the best thing to do is just punch
vladimir putin in the nose do you trust
this guy to do it this incompetent idiot
joe biden and this liberal establishment
that screwed everything up to the point
that we now don't have enough food to
feed ourselves do you trust this guy to
lead world war three for america
i don't
i do not
something that donald trump got really
really right more much more than the
democrats and frankly much more than
other republicans
is that he was not particularly
ideological
not every single issue for trump was a
fight between freedom and tyranny
between democracy and
autocracy
between freedom and repression no
donald trump
almost didn't view any issue in those
stark black and white ideological terms
he viewed a lot of it as a deal
as a as a little conflict that we got to
work out and you get this and i'll get
this the art of the deal call it
yeah well russia did this we've done
some bad things too yeah okay frankly
maybe trump went a little too far in
this regard but it allowed him much more
space to operate in his foreign policy
which is why his foreign policy was so
successful trump just came out he was
giving a rally he said
people always blamed my crazy
personality for almost getting us into
war he said it almost kept us out of war
and you remember this
the fake news media said my personality
would get us into war
but actually as it turned out it was my
personality
that kept us the hell out of war
and has been accurately reported
i was the only president in four decades
who did not get america into any new
conflicts instead i brought our troops
back home
from syria
iraq somalia and many other places and
would have done it
and would have done it very quickly from
afghanistan we were all set
and you know we didn't lose one soldier
in afghanistan for 18 months i spoke to
abdul the leader of the taliban
i said abdul don't do it abdul
and the fake news said oh he's speaking
to the taliban who the hell else am i
supposed to speak to
who the hell else am i supposed to be
too i kept him out of word that's so
true because trump did not use these
terms these
these flow these gigantic grandiose
ideas freedom versus autocracy putin
must be removed from power without even
thinking about what the consequences of
that could be
he didn't he actually didn't escalate
those conflicts he's when little rocket
man over there in korea says i'm i'm
gonna use my nuclear weapons what does
trump say he says i got a bigger button
and my button works watch it little
rocket man
and you don't know he's unpredictable
and he's giving people off ramps
and he's making jokes
and he's not
he's he's not escalating the conflict
steadily and steadily and steadily
the proof of the pudding is in the
tasting
during the trump presidency
we had relative peace
you cannot say the same certainly not
for joe biden
or obama
or bush
clinton maybe you had the dividend of
the cold the cold war had just ended so
you had this little period of relative
peace
maybe clinton deserves some credit for
that maybe not
but certainly the most recent presidents
you can't say that
trump had the better
record
because
he was not he was not fighting some
abstract ideological battle he was not
caught up in the stupidity of the
intellectual elite he's just saying no
look
you come after me i go after you he told
vladimir putin he said if you invade
ukraine i'm going to bomb moscow i'll
reduce the kremlin to ash
did he mean it no trump actually said
later on in a phone call he said putin
only believed me five to ten percent
that's all he needed to believe me
that's all he needed to believe me
and all the intellectuals clutched their
pearls and what did we get we got
relative peace and we got relative
prosperity and we got a booming economy
and we didn't have food shortages
speaking of big personalities and
comedians uh
crowder stephen crowder our pal has just
hit it out of the park
crowder has gone undercover
to investigate a new trend a new
important area of study in academia
fat studies
it turns out that there is an entire
academic discipline known as fat studies
home to peer-reviewed think pieces such
as overcoming fear of fat and queering
fat embodiment now i decided to write
and submit my very own fat studies paper
for presentation and with the help of my
brilliant researcher i wrote an entire
essay titled embracing fatness as
self-care in the era of trump i then
submitted the abstract to the conference
and uh oh did i say that i
wrote the essay i meant to say it was
submitted by c matheson a wonderful and
totally academically legitimate
genderqueer fat pride activist hello i
am c matheson i am an activist based out
of austin texas uh specifically working
with the non-binary and fat community uh
to help increase presence of
intersectional and non-binary people
with such events in austin as a women's
march march for our lives most recently
the global climate strikes my preferred
pronouns are
she and her and my paper embracing
fatness as self-care in the era of
donald trump
is something i'm thrilled to be
presenting and has been accepted here at
the new zealand fat studies conference
2020.
he's just he's just a genius he just
stephen crowder
he's a genius he's an intellectual he's
a scholar
according to
the fat studies department
fat studies got me thinking
of so many of our problems with the
ruling elite it's got me thinking of
katanji jackson brown or katanji brown
jackson i don't trust women that have
three names okay pick two you get a
first name and a last name ruth bader
ginsburg frankly even amy coney barrett
certainly christine blasey ford no you
get two names it's a slight digression
katanji jackson was asked
do
can you tell me what a woman is and
katanji jackson who has two degrees from
harvard said of course not
of course i can't tell you what a woman
is i only have two degrees from harvard
only an intellectual could be that
stupid we've got our
genius ruling class the adults are back
in town finally we've got responsible
people in the room running foreign
policy running domestic policy thank
goodness that cowboy trump is gone that
clown
now we've got
the intellectuals back in charge
and we don't have enough food
we have the break out of world war iii
and we don't have enough food
only an intellectual could be that
stupid sir roger scrutin the late great
conservative philosopher
he said that the job of a conservative
intellectual
is to articulate
in a in a high-minded way what common
people already know
and to articulate for for them what they
know intuitively that the geniuses and
the ruling elite and the intellectuals
what they
what they do not understand this stuff
doesn't need to be so complicated what
is a woman if you don't know it's hard
for me to tell you
but we we're living the consequences of
that right now and as we're looking down
the barrel at wars we're looking down
the barrel at food shortages as the best
our ruling class can tell us as gay gay
gay gay
i i think a lot of people
wish that our ruling elite were just
were a little bit less
educated a little less high-minded a
little less ideological and just
defended the basic things that we all
know are true and good for society
i guess i guess we'll have to keep
hoping through our our springtime of
famine and hunger as we get into joe
biden's summer
god help us all i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the pen shapiro show will smith
smacks chris rock upside the head at the
oscars president biden visits europe
where he proceeds to gaff all over
himself that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen